-My first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated actor,
a "New York Times"
best-selling author,
and a very, very,
very funny comedian.
He now stars in the television
series "The Moodys."
And you can see
the second season
Thursday nights at 9:30 on Fox.
Here is Denis Leary!
Oh, that's what
I'm talking about!
Yes!
-Hey, pal.
-Oh, I wish you were here,
buddy. Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, I know. You know what?
The first thing
I was going to say
is I just --
I can't believe I'm not there.
But listen,
I'm half vaxxed, okay?
-Good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm going to be fully vaxxed.
Half vaxxed is pretty much
what a lot of people probably
say about me
and how I do things.
But I'm half vaxxed.
I'll be fully vaxxed
in two weeks.
So, then, you know,
hopefully I'll be able
to come into the studio
and see you.
It's so weird not to be live,
you know?
-But we have like over 50 people
in the audience now.
So we actually have --
-That's what I heard.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So we're so happy
that you can even do this.
I know you're a big sports fan,
big Boston sports fan.
And I wanted to ask you about
Tom Brady
and how you felt,
him leaving the Patriots
and went on to win
the Super Bowl for Tampa Bay.
I know. Sorry to bring this up.
-So, listen. Sadly,
my plan didn't work out.
My plan was that Tom was going
to go to another team,
in this case, Tampa Bay,
and that team would suck,
and then he would come back.
So it didn't really work out,
my plan.
-No.
-So I was shocked,
'cause I'm like,
he's going to a team that has
pewter-colored football pants.
I mean, literally, pewter
is the color of their pants.
-Pewter. Oh, my gosh.
-I mean, his wife's --
His wife's a fashion model.
She must have said, "Honey, you
can't wear pewter-colored pants.
You can't."
-[ Laughs ]
-I couldn't be happier
that he won again.
And if there's any question
about him being
the greatest of all time now,
that's seven Super Bowls, right?
-Yeah.
-And you'd have to get
all of the other multiple Super
Bowl-winning quarterbacks --
There's very few --
And if they want to prove
they're the greatest
of all time,
throw the Lombardi Trophy
while you're drunk
from one boat to another boat.
-That's the ultimate --
-That's the test.
-That's exactly right.
That's exactly right.
-That's the test.
-I want to talk about this.
You do this every year,
this show called
"Comics Come Home"
in Boston.
-Yes.
-And I'm lucky enough to be
involved with it whenever I can,
whenever -- Every year
I've been going whenever I can.
It benefits
Cam Neely Foundation.
And we perform. I do stand-up,
or I make you sing a song.
-Yeah.
-And I got this footage
I wanted to show you,
because do you remember
when you surprised me?
-Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Is this footage
from the John Mayer thing?
-Yeah.
-Okay, you have to
let me set it up.
I love when Jimmy comes,
because we end up singing
a song together, you know?
Which is a blast.
So, I call John Mayer
without telling Jimmy.
And I say, "Listen,
I have an idea.
You come on the show.
You play --
Jimmy wants to do
'Walk This Way.'
You play 'Walk This Way,' but
we don't tell Jimmy in advance.
So Jimmy doesn't find out
until you walk onstage
during the song.
Like, you'll start the riff.
[ Vocalizing "Walk This Way" ]
Offstage."
[ Vocalizing ]
You and I start singing.
Now, for people who have
never sung that song,
that's an incredibly
difficult song to sing,
not because of the, you know,
the level of the notes.
It's because the lyrics
are jam-packed,
and they're unbelievably fast.
Right?
-Yeah.
-So Jimmy and I had rehearsed it
as trading lines back and forth.
So, you know, if one guy
misses a line,
you're kind of screwed, right?
Jimmy comes out.
[ Vocalizing "Walk This Way" ]
And me and Jimmy
start doing the song.
John Mayer walks out onstage.
The crowd goes nuts,
which they're supposed to.
And Jimmy stopped singing.
[ Laughter ]
Completely.
I figured he'd look
at John Mayer and be surprised.
He looks at John Mayer
like he's surprised
and then goes over
and starts hugging John Mayer
and, like, hanging out with him.
I'm like -- I'm singing
the entire song by myself.
[ Laughter ]
For like two verses.
-No -- Really?
-Yeah.
-I don't remember that --
But I just wanted
to show you a clip.
I didn't know --
I forgot that I did that.
Here's, I guess, the moment
where I spot John Mayer
surprising me at "Comics
Come Home" with Denis Leary.
Take a look.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
-I was like, "Hey!"
-You can hear me singing
in the background.
-I knew the guitar sounded good,
and your band is always great,
but I was like,
"That guitar sounds great."
And then I was like [Vocalizes]
And I was about to go like,
"She starts swinging."
And I go, "Hey, dude!
What's going on?"
-You literally -- I kept
singing -- I looked at you,
and I was like, "He's not
going to keep singing."
So now I'm on the teleprompter
singing your lines, right?
Because I don't know your lines.
[ Laughter ]
And I look over, and you're
dancing with John Mayer.
And I literally, at one point,
went like, "Hey, let's go!"
Unbelievable.
-Denis, I want to talk to you
about your show, buddy.
I want to talk
about "The Moodys."
-Yes.
-Here we go.
This is -- It's a family sitcom.
Elizabeth Perkins, super funny.
You get to play hockey,
which is cool.
-Yeah, I get to play hockey.
So, I'll give you the setup.
You know, it's a limited series
every time it comes on.
So, the first time we did it,
it was about family Christmas.
This year, there's
a family wedding that --
It starts out the first
15 seconds of episode 1.
You know that the wedding
didn't go well.
And then we flash back.
The kids have been locked down
with us in the pandemic,
like a lot of us in real life.
-Yep.
-And now the pandemic's over
and two of them leave,
and then they come right back.
So we're really getting
on each other's nerves
even after the pandemic,
and everybody's supposed
to be living out on their own.
I think that's what
the clip's about.
-Yeah. It's super funny.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Denis Leary in
the new season of "The Moodys."
Take a look.
-Hey, look at this.
All three of my adult children
living at home,
eating my food,
and using my gas-powered heat.
How delightful.
So, right now,
I'm going to go over
to the fridge
and get some cream.
And there better be enough
left for my coffee,
'cause if there isn't,
I'm going to find the culprit,
and I will have two of my adult
children living at home with me.
Uh-oh.
Oh, that's -- it's not good.
Ooh, this just --
I don't think it's going to --
Ah.
Mm...
Well, yes.
We remain a family of five.
-Yay.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah!
Denis Leary, everybody.